in the 48 hours since I released my
first code interpreter video I believe I
have found another 12 use cases that
showcase its power from finding errors
in data sets to reading Anna Karenina
ASCII art to image captioning most of
these I haven't seen anyone else mention
so let's begin first is creating a 3D
surface plot which you can see on the
left from the image on the right I know
I will get two professional uses in a
second but I was personally very
impressed that all of this that you can
see can be done through the interface of
chat GPT you can even see the little
buildings at the bottom left reflected
in this 3D surface plot to give you an
idea of how it works you click on the
button to the left of the chat box and
then it analyzes whatever you've
uploaded and all I said was analyze the
RGB of the pixels and output a 3D
surface map of the colors of the image
now I will admit it doesn't do a perfect
job immediately at first it wasn't down
downloadable and then it wasn't big
enough but eventually I got it to work
but it's time for the next example and
what I wondered was what is the biggest
document I could upload to get it to
analyze the longest book that I've ever
read is Anna Karenina I think it's about
a thousand pages long and I pasted it
into a word doc and it's about 340 000
words I uploaded it and then I asked as
you can see find all mentions of England
analyze them to discover the tone in
which the country is perceived in the
book now I know what some of you may be
wondering is it just using its stored
knowledge of the book and I'll get to
that in a second but look at what it did
it went through and found the relevant
quotes there are seven of them there I
checked the document and these were
legitimate quotes but here's where we
get to something that you can't just do
with Ctrl F in a Word document it
analyze the tone and sentiment of each
of these passages and you can see the
analysis here then I asked drawing on
your own knowledge of the 19th century
and the finding above write a two
thousand word reflection on the
presentation of England in Anna Karenina
now I know many of you won't be
interested in that book but imagine your
own text this is 340
000 words it then created a somewhat
beautiful essay and yes it did bring up
each of those quotes with analysis now
here is where things get kind of wild
just to demonstrate that it's not using
its own knowledge I asked the same
question in a different window without
of course uploading the file and at
first I was like oh damn it did it here
are the quotes wow it did the job it
didn't even need the document but that
was until I actually checked out whether
the quotes were legitimate and lo and
behold it had made up the quotes I
searched far and wide for these quotes
and unless I'm going completely crazy
they are completely made up so when it
found those quotes earlier it wasn't
drawing upon its own knowledge it was
finding them from the document and this
also serves as a warning of the
hallucinations that the model can do if
it doesn't have enough data I'm going to
get back to reliability and factuality
in a moment but just quickly a bonus I
got it to write an epilogue to The Death
of Ivan Elliott an incredible short
story by Leo Tolstoy and as some people
had asked it can indeed output that to a
PDF which is convenient for many people
next what about multiple files I didn't
actually investigate this in my previous
video which if you haven't watched by
the way please do check it out there's
23 examples of use cases there but
anyway what I wanted to try out was I
wanted to upload four data sets and then
I wanted to get gpt4 to find any
correlations between the data sets also
I was kind of investigating if there was
a limit to the number of files you could
upload and honestly there doesn't seem
to be I picked this global data almost
at random to be honest it was the amount
of sugar consumed per person and then
the murder rate per 100 000 people and
then the inequality index of each of
those countries and the population aged
20 to 39 but first notice how it didn't
stop me I could could just keep
uploading files and then it would ask me
things like please provide guidance on
the kind of analysis or specific
questions you would like me to
investigate with these four data sets so
it's still aware of the previous files
what I asked was this analyze all four
data sets and find five surprising
correlations output as many insights as
you can distinguishing between
correlation and causation this is really
pushing the limits of what code
interpreter can do but it did it many of
you asked before if it could be lulled
with false data into giving bad
conclusions and it's really hard to get
it to do that dbt4 is honestly really
smart and increasingly hard to fall you
can read what it said it found a very
weak negative correlation for example
between sugar consumption and murder and
then just admitted there is probably no
significant relationship between these
two factors but notice it then found a
correlation that it found more plausible
there is a moderate positive correlation
0.4 between the murder rate per 100 000
people and the Ginny inequality Index
this suggests that countries with higher
income inequality tend to have a higher
murder rate I Then followed up with this
drawing on your own knowledge of the
world which correlation seems the most
causally related it then brought in
research from the field of social
science and gave a plausible explanation
about why this correlation might exist
obviously this was just my example you
would have to think about all the
different files and data sets that you
were willing to upload to find
correlations and surprising insights
within I'm gonna try to alternate
between fun and serious so the next one
is going to be kind of fun I was
surprised by the number of comments
asking me to get it to do ASCII art now
you may remember from the last video
that I got it to analyze this image and
yes I asked it to turn it into ASCII art
and here is what it came up with not bad
not amazing but not bad a bit more
seriously now for data analytics what I
wanted to do is test if it could spot an
error in a mass passive CSV or Excel
file this is a huge data set of
population density and notice what I did
I say notice you almost certainly
wouldn't be able to notice but basically
for the Isle of Man for 1975 I changed
105 which was the original to 1 500 and
I did something similar for Lichtenstein
for a different year then I uploaded the
file and said find any anomalies in the
data by looking for implausible percent
changes year to year output any data
points that look suspicious and really
interestingly here the wording does make
a difference you've got to give it a
tiny hint if you just say find anything
that looks strange it will find empty
cells and say oh there's a missing cell
here but if you give it a tiny nudge and
just say that you're looking for
anomalies look out for things like
implausible percent changes data that
looks suspicious then look what it did
it did the analysis and you can see the
reasoning above and it found the Isle of
Man and Liechtenstein and it said these
values are indeed very unusual and may
indicate errors in the data it said it's
also possible that these changes could
be due to significant population
migration changes in land area or other
factors I guess if in one year one of
those places was invaded and it was only
a city that was left officially as part
of the territory the population density
would Skyrocket so that's a smart answer
but it spotted the two changes that I'd
made among thousands of data points in
fact actually I'm going to work out how
many data points there were in that file
I used Excel to work out of course and
there were 36 000 data points and I made
two changes and it spotted both of them
but now it's time to go back to
something a bit more fun and creative
next I gave it that same image again and
I said write a sonnet about a more full
AI reflecting on a dystopian landscape
he does look kind of solemn hair overlay
the poem in the background of this image
using Edge detector to avoid any objects
now there there are different ways of
doing it it can detect the foreground
and background so it put the text away
from the central character I think the
final result is really not bad and the
sonnet is pretty powerful I'll read just
the ending gone are the humans it once
adored leaving it in silent Solitude in
binary sorrow it has stored memories of
a world it wants new in the void it
sends a mournful cry a ghost in the
machine left to die anyway this is a
glimpse of the power of merging Gypsy
Ford's language abilities with its
nascent code interpreter abilities next
people asked about unclean data so I
tried to find the most unclean data I
could find what I did is I pasted in
directly from a website Real Clear
Politics a bunch of polls different
polls and notice the formatting is quite
confusing you've got the dates on top
you have missing data colored data all
sorts of things then I asked extract out
the data for the 2024 Republican
Presidential nomination analyze the
trend in the data and output the results
in a new downloadable file it's sorted
through and then found the averages for
each of the candidates in that specific
race and I'm going to get to factuality
and accuracy just a bit later on the
hint is that the accuracy is really
surprisingly good I wanted to push it a
bit further and do some Trend analysis
so first to analyze some of the other
races from that very unclean data set
and then what I did is I pasted in an
article from Politico and based on this
very messy data I got it to do some
political prognostication it analyzed
the article and the polls and then I
think gave quite a smart and nuanced
answer and what about accuracy I know
many people had that question well I
uploaded this data and I'm also going to
link to it in the description so you can
do further checks it was based on a
fictional food company based in Boston
and New York and what I asked was draw
six actionable insights that would be
relevant for the CEO of of this company
it then gave the insights below and even
though I didn't actually ask for this it
gave six visualizations let me zoom in
here so you can see it and then I picked
out a random five of those data points
obviously I'm not going to check
hundreds of them but I picked out five
then I laboriously checked them in Excel
and they were all right obviously though
I'm not guaranteeing that every single
calculation is correct and as I say you
can download the file and see if these
six visualizations are correct yourself
so far honestly it's looking good and
then below we have more detail on those
insights and then some actions that we
could take as a CEO just like I did with
Anna Karenina I Then followed up and
said use your own knowledge of the world
and offer plausible explanations for
each of these findings this is where GT4
becomes your own data analyst assistant
and it gave plausible explanations for
some of the findings for example the
higher sales in the east region could be
due to a higher population density
better distribution networks or higher
demand for the company's products and at
this point you could either use the web
browser plugin to do more research on
your own or you could upload more files
I actually asked and I think this is a
great question suggest six other company
data sets you would find helpful to
access to test these suppositions now
obviously a lot is going to come down to
privacy and data protection but gpt4
code interpreter can suggest further
files that would help it with its
analytics and it gives those below and
again the lazy CEO could just upload
those files and get gpt4 code
interpreter to do further analysis you
don't have to think about what to upload
gpd4 will suggest it for you whether
that's advisable or not I'll leave you
to decide the next one is slightly less
serious and it's that code interpreter
can output PowerPoint slides directly
now I know when Microsoft 365 copilot
rolls out this might be a little bit
redundant but it is cool to know you can
output directly into PowerPoint the
visualizations and Analysis from code
interpreter now on to mathematics and
many people pointed out that I didn't
fully test out Wolfram to give it a fair
shot so I tested both code interpreter
and Wolfram on differential equations
and they both got it right interestingly
though they gave you a link for the
step-by-step Solutions because this is a
paid option on the Wolfram website but I
did find some other differences between
them and honestly it favored code
interpreter so here is a really
challenging mathematics question and
Wolfram can't get it right it says that
the answer is 40 even though that's not
one of the options and yes it used
Wolfram I think about five times here
was the exact same prompt except instead
of saying use Wolfram I said use code
interpreter and this was not a one-off
example it fairly consistently got it
right so code interpreter does indeed
have some serious oomph behind it just
quickly again on the silly stuff I
uploaded the entire Death of Ivan Elliot
short story by Tolstoy then I changed
one phrase in one line out of about 23
000 words I changed his daughter into an
astronaut of course if you just ask gpd4
directly it doesn't have enough space it
will give you this message the message
you submitted was too long please reload
the conversation but with code
interpreter it did spot the mistake now
again you do have to give it a little
bit of help I said anything about the
daughter in the story that seems strange
and after thinking for a while it did
eventually get it it said the phrase
despite being a shogoth astronaut seems
to be out of place in the 19th century
context so this does strike me as a
somewhat sneaky albeit imperfect way of
getting around the context limit you
can't input all the words directly you
have to upload the file and then you do
have to give a slight indication of what
you're looking for in the file but for
many use cases it is a way to get the
desired result without using up too much
money as we come to the end here I'm
going to leave in the background a
beautiful fractal visualization done
through code interpreter as before let
me know if there's anything that I've
missed or further experiments you would
want me to do I honestly don't know when
they're going to roll this out more
widely I know it's going to have a lot
of use cases both professionally and
personally and that's before you bring
in advanced prompt engineering like
smart gbt and tree of thought prompting
again if you haven't seen my other video
on the code interpreter plugin please do
check it out there are about 23
experiments I did just as good as the
ones you can see here thank you for
watching to the end and have a wonderful
day